>> Pete: KRISTIN, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE LATEST
INFORMATION.
JOINING ME NOW TO REACT IS AN
ATTORNEY AND TRUMP 2020
ADVISORY COUNCIL MEMBER AND AN
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY.
YOU AND I ARE HEARING THESE
RESULTS IN REALTIME.
I HAVE THE U.S./MEXICO JOINT
DECLARATION IN FRONT OF ME.
MEXICO NATIONAL GUARD TO THEIR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
MIGRANTS LOOKING FOR ASYLUM
SENT BACK TO MEXICO.
AND THE WHOLE THING REVIEWED 90
DAYS FROM NOW TO SEE WHETHER OR
NOT MEXICO IS FULFILLING IT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS AND
CONSIDER WHAT AMERICA GAVE UP,
WHICH IS A TARIFF THAT NEVER
WAS IMPOSED BUT WAS THREATENED,
YOUR REACTION.
>> TARIFFS ARE NOT THE FAVORED
TOOL OF MOST CONSERVATIVES,
PETE.
DESPERATE TIMES CALL FOR
DESPERATE MEASURES.
HERE IT WORKED.
I THINK IT IS A GREAT RESULT
FOR AMERICA AND A PRETTY GOOD
RESULT FOR MEXICO AS WELL.
BECAUSE MEXICO HAS BEEN GETTING
THE BENEFIT OF ALLOWING THE
CURRENT SITUATION.
A LOT OF REMITTANCES, $40
BILLION GOING BACK TO MEXICO
EVERY YEAR.
IT IS NOT WORKING.
SO NEIGHBORS NEED TO WORK OUT
THEIR DISPUTES AND NOW IN
ADDITION TO THE TERMS THAT YOU
MENTIONED, IT IS ALSO GOING TO
INCLUDE THE NATIONAL GUARD
STANDING THROUGHOUT MEXICO
INTERDICTING GANGS AND
SMUGGLING RINGS AND HELPING
WITH THAT AND ALSO PROVIDING
SOME SUPPORT AND EVEN
POTENTIALLY JOBS TO THOSE
ASYLUM SEEKERS WAITING FOR
THEIR APPLICATIONS TO BE
PROCESSED IN AMERICA.
I THINK IT WILL BE GREAT FOR
THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE SEEKING TO
COME TO THIS COUNTRY AS WELL.
THEY CAN BE IN A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT AND BE SUPPORTED IN
MEXICO WHILE AMERICA MAKES A
DETERMINATION WHETHER THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE OR NOT.
>> Pete: FRANCISCO, YOU
UNDERSTAND HOW DYSFUNCTIONAL
THIS OPERATION IS.
IS THIS A WIN FOR THE WHITE
HOUSE AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE?
>> IT IS SMOKE AND MIRRORS.
PEOPLE, WE AREN'T EVEN TALKING
IMMIGRATION REFORM.
GUYS, NOT ONLY ARE WE NOW
ADMITTING WE CAN'T GET THE WALL
BUILT.
WE'RE NOW ADMITTING.
-- MEXICO IS NOT GOING TO PAY
FOR THE WALL AND WORSE, WE'RE
GOING TO PAY FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF JOBS IN MEXICO.
NOT ONLY ARE WE ADMITTING
MEXICO WON'T PAY FOR THE WALL.
WE'LL GIVE THEM MONEY TO EMPLOY
THE CENTRAL AMERICANS WHO DON'T
COME HERE AND
>> Pete: THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE
DOING.
>> WE'RE NOT GIVING THEM ANY
MONEY.
>> READ BETWEEN THE LINES.
THEY'RE SAYING EMPLOYMENT --
>> I'M READING THE LINES.
THE LINES ARE THAT MEXICO WILL
OFFER JOBS TO FOLKS WHO HAVE
CONVENIENT IN THE MIGRANT
CARAVANS.
WE'RE NOT PAYING FOR THE
DEPLOYMENT OF THEIR NATIONAL
GUARDS, WE'RE NOT PAYING FOR
ASYLUM SEEKERS SENT BACK TO
MEXICO.
ULTIMATELY -- HOW CAN YOU NOT
KNOWLEDGE -- HOLD ON, GUYS.
FRANCISCO.
>> THE REASON PEOPLE ARE COMING
FROM MEXICO IS BECAUSE MEXICO
CAN'T PROVIDE JOBS FOR ITS OWN
CITIZENS.
>> IT DOESN'T WANT TO, NOT
CAN'T.
>> THEY CANNOT.
>> Pete: WOULD YOU ACKNOWLEDGE
THEIR OWN GOVERNMENT AND THE
CARTELS ARE FACILITATING THIS.
IF WE CAN GET A CRACKDOWN AS
PEOPLE ARE COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY IT'S A WIN FOR BOTH
COUNTRIES AND THE HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS AT OUR BORDER.
WHY CAN'T YOU ACKNOWLEDGE --
>> STICKING OUR HEAD IN THE
SAND.
>> Pete: STEPS IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
>> THERE IS NO STEP.
WE'LL END UP PAYING FOR IT.
AT LEAST AS LONG AS YOU GUYS
AGREE THAT WE AREN'T GOING TO
BUILD A WALL.
IS THAT WHAT YOU GUYS ARE
AGREEING ON THAT?
>> WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THAT.
THAT'S A SEPARATE ISSUE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN THE NEXT FEW DAYS.
>> Pete: YOU CAN TAKE IT UP
WITH THE COURTS DISRUPTING THE
PRESIDENT'S PLANS.
THAT'S NOT -- YOU'RE TRYING TO
DISTRACT AWAY FROM A CLEAR
VICTORY.
>> IT ISN'T JUST A POLITICAL
IT IS A HUMAN RIGHTS VICTORY.
CHILDREN ARE BEING SMUGGLED AND
ABUSED.
GIRLS RAPED.
THIS IS A HUMAN RIGHTS
PERSPECTIVE.
WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT.
WE CAN'T WAIT FOR DEMOCRATS AND
FAKE REPUBLICANS WHO AREN'T
WILLING TO PROTECT OUR COUNTRY.
WE HAVE TO DO IT TODAY.
>> Pete: HOW ARE YOU NOT
POINTING AT CONGRESS?
>> I AM POINTING AT CONGRESS,
ABSOLUTELY.
THEY FAILED TO DO THEIR JOB,
WHICH CAUSED US TO COME WITH
WITH THESE CRAZY IDEAS.
>> Pete: IT BROUGHT AN
OPPORTUNITY WHERE WE HAVE NEW
CONCESSIONS FROM MEXICO AND
WE'LL REVIEW THEM IN 90 DAYS.
HOW IS THAT NOT A WIN?
>> MEXICO WON'T PAY THE TARIFFS.
YOU AND I WERE.
OUR PRICES WOULD GO UP.
>> THERE ARE NO TARIFFS.
MEXICO IS PAYING FOR THE
NATIONAL GUARD AND PAYING TO
HOUSE AND PROVIDE JOBS FOR THE
REFUGEES.
READ THE REPORT.
READ THE AGREEMENT.
IT IS VERY CLEAR.
>> YOU HAVEN'T EVEN READ THE
AGREEMENT.
IT HAPPENED IN THE LAST HOUR.
>> I READ IT.
I READ IT.
>> Pete: I KNOW IT SAYS WE
AREN'T PAYING JOBS FOR MIGRANTS
IN MEXICO.
THAT'S WHAT IT DOESN'T SAY.
>> MEXICO IS PAYING FOR IT.
MEXICO IS PAYING FOR IT.
>> Pete: IN THE MEANTIME WE GET
TO PROTECT OUR SOVEREIGNTY.
>> LET'S COME BACK TOMORROW AND
SHOW ME WHERE IT SAYS MEXICO
WILL PAY FOR THE JOBS.
>> WE'LL BE EVALUATING IT IN 90
DAYS.
>> Pete: COME JOIN US ON "FOX &
FRIENDS" IN THE MORNING AND
WE'LL TALK ABOUT IT.
WE HAVE TO LEAVE IT THERE.
IT'S TOUGH WHEN YOU TRY TO
DEBATE SOMETHING AND THERE IS A
WIN AND WE CAN'T EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGE